Miz isn't going to be happy today why
are you happy first is that right first
person on my list and I was like you
know I go I go where's Sam and he goes
dude there he's first I couldn't say no
no way yeah I couldn't say no by the way
when I asked what am i doing Sam
yeah I'm not sure if we're doing are you
kidding I literally I felt a rage inside
of oh there was a huge rage and then
I'll say oh no he's first yeah I got
better better be first and we don't take
a lot of guests in the first hour
why don't you what do you mean why why
wouldn't you because usually we like to
set the table in the first hour and then
we start to get things moving in the
second you think you are Howard Stern I
mean come on I don't know what hours you
take what you get okay you're the type
of talent that takes what you can get
look we're a giant show here on Sirius
you're huge you're so huge that and then
Jim didn't even decide to show up today
well I think that might have something
to do with you that loves me I was
worried you're gonna be upset he never
hangs out here exactly every you visit
me is it something I said
I feel feeling I always promote him and
I always think his comedy is absolutely
fantastic and I always sit there and say
I watched his Netflix specials all the
time and and then when I come here he's
right here I promote him all the time
yeah he's actually on a flight to San
Francisco right now because he's playing
in San Francisco this weekend oh he's so
cool so you know he's a jet setter
himself obviously you're not well I
don't know if you've heard a man the
ship there's a big event happening
actually in this town this week there
that I'm what are you doing on it I'll
be I've got kickoff show fever are you
still making fun of me calling me old
and stuff
look I there was there was a moment on
the last kickoff show
I got your waiver oh I remember I heard
it I did say that the MS was 40 and it
was a little too not 40 I'm 38 thank you
very much
I'm in my prime this is like prime time
for me I think so too but I also think
that you know you running around at your
age saying you know I just wish that my
dad loved me more is like a little you
know we're grown-ups here we are grown
ups you know I was actually curious
about that too like how our fans WWE
fans would be able to take that because
our fans like a little hardcore like a
little bit more aggressive but I
honestly feel it's relatable as well
like my family and I didn't realize this
as well like some
cousin's like my dad's brothers and
sisters they actually came up to me and
went after they saw my dad say you know
I love you I'm proud he goes wow I can't
believe your dad said that and I go why
I guess my dad's never said that either
like why I go what you're kidding that's
my dad's brother and then my other
cousins from the other my dad's other
brother they're like yeah us either and
I went really like that and so we
actually had a bonding moment with my
cousins about that because it was one of
those things like yeah we never heard
you always do want your parents approval
always no matter what I think
and maybe that's generational too cuz
like I'll be on the phone with my dad
and like we'll be about to hang up and
my wife will be next to me and she'll be
mouthing say I love you say I love you
that's funny I'm going like why would I
say that's though my me and my mother
every time I must phone I love you I
love you right I love you I love you but
my dad alright see you later
so you're saying that like because you
start succeeding at a young it you get
on the real world you know as a kid yeah
you know you got on tough enough like
you've you've got a lot of
accomplishments under your belt still
not good enough as all this is happening
nothing oh my god
no not really I mean it's like yeah you
know cofee still his favorite you know
by the way my favorite big dope knew
about Kofi before everybody else did my
dad was on the Kofi train way back when
you speaking Jamaican right right yeah
that's the guy right there so my dad's
been on the Kofi train for a very long
time now my dad being a part of WWE you
know being actually getting a little
notoriety from miz and miz's as well as
WWE oh my god it's ridiculous like my
dad's like so you're doing an action
assigning am I am I gonna be signing
with you or is that bad what do you what
are you kidding no I know you're not
signing with me goes well you know I
usually you know Hall of Fame I usually
do interviews and that I go
dad you're the worst interview in the in
the entire place that's why they do it
it's a joke there's no I they love it
they love what I do they think I'm funny
yeah it is funny because you're so bad
your dad looks nothing like you
thank you like you can't you can't when
you look at your dad you're like what
he's got like long hair oh my god is not
clean cut it on my mom basically I think
I get my style from my mom my dad
doesn't care what like he wears a Jack
Cleveland Casino jacket every day every
day of his life like the same
I didn't even know the timeline at a
casino we do we do my dad's there every
single look you want to meet my dad go
to the casino I guarantee you'll see
them every day
you know what your dad kind of looks
like it I hope you don't take this
disrespectfully he kind of looks like
you ever see Boogie Nights but yes if
Philip Seymour Hoffman's character and
Boogie Nights got older it kind of looks
like what your dad I think I'm getting a
lot I mean I get Sponge Bob Squarepants
as dad so I mean my dad's great though I
mean he's been having a lot of fun with
it and you know it was interesting
because like the first time I actually
heard my cat say I love you is in front
of 20,000 people and that was legit it
was legit like that was a real real
moment that I got to experience and
honestly I thought the WW audience was
just gonna like boo or crap all over it
but it was really it was emotional it
was amazing and I think everyone felt it
in the audience and it was great yeah
well they actually were like they they
probably you can figure out when you're
watching something that's just a
complete put on yeah and when there's
something real going on even if it's not
you know if it's if it's a story that's
based on reality when there's that I'm
such a great a great actor that you
wouldn't be able to tell really
yes oh okay I mean have you seen the
marine six five four and three I have my
Christmas movies my favorite is five I
think is it I think that's the memo
Dallas yeah that's what it was
um do you I mean so is your dad happy
for you about the Snickers thing because
I'm looking right here and you know
Snickers puts the do not usual mania is
presented by Snickers this this this
upcoming uh it's huge coming season and
your catchphrases on a snicker not only
that but like it's crazy like never in
my wildest dreams did I think I would
ever accomplish it I mean I was guy like
from Parma Ohio you know when you go to
Parma Ohio you go to college after
college go to back to Parma and you have
a job that's what you do for the rest of
your life but when I go in the real
world and then started doing more and
more and more like everything everyone's
like winner winner is it enough when is
it enough it's like things just keep
happening writing better like right now
I feel like I'm in my prime I'm really
feeling my groove like fans are behind
me for the first time and I think my
entire career and it feels real it
doesn't feel like a put-on like oh we're
just gonna cheer for you because that's
what we're supposed to do it feels like
they're really behind me what does it
feel like has you've been there
when you're like okay we're taking the
MS who's been the bad guy forever and
we're gonna make you into a good guy and
it and it doesn't or it wasn't even oh
my god what does that feel what is I I
remember when when it was like yeah
you're gonna become a good guy and I was
like dude you don't want to do that you
know what I'm gonna work I knew I knew
it'd be and I go I go what am I gonna do
that is good you know you're gonna keep
being you keep being me I'm arrogant
I'm an egotistical I am NOT likeable
right I know when I walk in a room
uh-huh like when the first time people
meet me I don't put off a good like
maybe it's a good vibe people laugh but
he goes ah he's a jerk not again you're
not a first impression laughing it's a
laughing jerk like oh he's a jerk you
know he's you know kinda cocky kind of
arrogant egotistical I like him but yeah
yeah I'll pull him yeah he's fun to poo
right you know I'm that guy so when they
when they first brought me in and I was
heel a bad guy for oh I don't know what
ten years and then they were like yeah
you're gonna become a good guy and I
went all right what am i doing that's
good
nothing I went oh my god this is this is
gonna be terrible and it was it was hard
but the thing was thank you not asking
you I'm saying so it was horrible back
me up he couldn't like no it wasn't that
bad no no no I remember it I if you're
asked my opinion it was not your best
time it was not it was and it wasn't fun
because the crowd I mean the crowd which
is kind of cheer just cuz that's what
we're supposed to do you're the good guy
we don't like that other guy we like you
a little more so now if you like the
Olympic wedding I can really feel it
happening and to bring it to wrap
everything around now to have a Snickers
bar at Dollar General where you can go
and like pick up my Snickers bar like
it's mine right awesome one they made it
for me right like that's nuts
yeah why is that a pun because of
Snickers huh peanuts it's nuts
yeah which is fabulous I see it creamy
it's smooth it's great almond butter
peanut butter we got it all I mean my
favorite is the ice cream bar you love
the ice cream every time like every time
I go like I'm driving on the road and we
drive everywhere I mean it's it's being
a WAV superstar you travel all over the
world and you know that every gas
station has an ice-cream Snickers and
that is my go to like you know we're
talking to go to candy from
yeah would you like all of them are yeah
I don't make my shirt off on juvie
yeah I look at you and I go this guy
just eats candy all day gimme fat
personified I mean that's what you do
yeah yeah it's just every jungle workout
I've recently started working you're
kidding right what would your workouts I
do I'm very curious at your workouts
okay I'm glad you asked I do I workout
two to three times a week 45-minute
sessions and it is that it's at a
strongman but personal trainer okay have
a trainers training me at a strongman
gym I was just doing strongman strongly
so it's not much cardio it's no carpet
no CrossFit no we live wing squats so
what do you want like what do you want
your body to be like why are you going
just to get my I mean I've really looked
at myself and I'm like I'm 35 years old
I look like a melted candle I'm gonna be
dead by the time I'm 38 or 40 oh I mean
you look older than me
you think so I think so why don't have I
don't have a Hollywood glam squad
following me around I don't have a glam
squad following me around thank you very
much but that's a compliment but is it I
think so I don't think so I think it was
a very a very little snarky wait it's
kind of a Sam Roberts kind of way of
saying yeah he's 40 no I was an honest
mistake but you know I'm I'm I'm
stronger now than I was when I started
to feel like you're stronger than
absolute you feel better about yourself
like when you're done at the gym dear
are you like well I had a really good
workout like I did yes because sometimes
when you don't do cardio and like when
you first start going you're just doing
power like you don't seem like a guy
that that wants to be powerful you seem
like a guy that you just want to feel
good yeah no I like walking out wobbly
legs okay feeling it yeah yeah whatever
I move that oh my god yeah how's your
diet changed see that's that's what I'm
working on yeah that's yeah you can't be
no like the other candies and stuff
that's a tough one I you know of course
we'll make time for a Snickers every now
and then that cause hungry why wait yeah
why would you wait I wait you're not you
exactly you're just not you like you'd
come out here and you just be like you
know Jim Norton not here right exactly
non-existent exactly so I'll still have
a Snickers every now and then but yes I
do that's that's the next phase that we
haven't gotten to yet the diet so the
thing is if you're not the die
is 90% of everything [ __ ] I was helping
more like 50/50 no it is it is 100% like
if you really want to feel good and and
and really start feeling yourself you
need to get a good diet right fast food
nutrition no oh okay all right no that's
a ok you know they nowadays you can
really get these meal supplements that
like these meal meal plan places that
literally and you probably don't like
those yeah I see a lot of you guys with
a pasta or like I see a lot of you guys
you go and there's all this catering at
WWE but but you you have here your meal
supplement you go in and and and it's
they they deliver them to you but I've
never looked at one of those I try meals
hilarious yeah I found upon it too I
always make fun of Seamus like for
always bringing his food on the road and
then all of a sudden like I was like man
I I'm gonna I'm a good guy now and it's
a completely different breath of air
like it's it's a lot different cardio so
I was like man I got a I mean in the way
you're actually know when you're the way
you're moving yeah like I'm so used to a
different pace as I see I but as a good
guy you're in a different pace like for
instance when you're getting beat up by
a good guy that good guy needs to
celebrate afterwards you know and he's I
get everybody all fired up executive
fired up but he just got done beating a
guy up you're out of breath hey the
first time I did that I went oh my so I
literally I was like I sent out to like
I lost like 12 pounds in the past month
and I've also had no idea so Seth
Rollins has a whole Dead Boys workout
right huh Dead Boys fitness and I've
been doing his workouts so he's a big
E's across face across monster I'm gonna
big on CrossFit but to think some of the
things that I like are very cardio esque
and get my air going yeah and so then I
also do stuff like I look on YouTube
just for like workouts and stuff did
anybody warned you like being a good guy
is way more physically exhausting no yes
- it's just getting used to it it's a
different breath of air like it's not
less necessarily like oh being a bad guy
is like less cardio no it's just a
different type of cardio I see I see
now you wouldn't understand all you do
is power lift that's true power lift Sam
Roberts that's true I'm just I'm just
mister squats over here I don't underst
squats I don't understand
look at you fit in your pants like well
like or your your your with these Isis
bulging out it but yeah look at that can
you see my mind you wear skinny jeans
that's right that's on purpose so that
my life so hitting trendy you look like
you're from Brooklyn thank you very very
much
Brooklyn by the way where people will be
able to see NXT takeover tomorrow Hall
of Fame on Saturday rod smackdown on
Monday and Tuesday but WrestleMania is
on Sunday
MetLife MetLife Stadium you a thousand
strong 80,000 people to watch you have a
presented by Snickers presented by
Snickers which is awesome and glorious
and ravishing and Brut there you go
that's right of course it's all general
do you sit there and go is there a
different type of pressure to wrestling
a McMahon at a Wrestlemania you have a
match with Shane McMahon it's a
no-holds-barred pinfalls count anywhere
match so and I think of this on two
levels number one Shane McMahon is a
maniac anybody that knows anything about
wrestling has seen Shane McMahon do the
absolute most crazy things imagine a man
if you're a McMahon you're a maniac
exactly s well said and if it's no rules
no holds barred you've got to do some
ridiculous stuff but at the same time
the McMahons are the most valuable asset
to the company so you got to take care
of them right are they I think so I
think I'm the most valuable asset to
this company
look I'm a how many superstars and how
many people in general in the entire
history of WWE I've done what I've done
and can do what I do how many people do
you have an interview with and you go
wow that was a great interview not only
did we get all our plugs in but we it
felt like a natural smooth conversation
no you're great you're great man but at
the same time you're great you fanboying
out for the McMahons look it's an
advanced way she didn't marry eight the
WWE Shane McMahon did not create it
Vince McMahon did and I'll tell you what
Vince McMahon's dad did but Vince made
it global worldwide visit fantastic
business man but the fact of the matter
is his son stepped over the bounds and
now at WrestleMania he's got a Falls
Count Anywhere match with me and I'm
gonna beat him up in front of you know
eighty thousand people and the reason
why I wanted Falls got anywhere it's cuz
I want to be him so beat him up right in
front of all these fans like I want them
to be up close and personal and see my
fist in his face I see that Hall
because that's what that's I mean he put
his hands on my you put your hands on me
that's fine
hands on my family it's a whole nother
ballgame so you're playing going into
the stands of the stadium going into my
yeah to get up close and personal like I
want a person that is as paid for their
seat up in front to be able to witness
might my fist go through Shane's face
Wow
that's what I want now Travis you're
sitting in club seating at WrestleMania
that's right will you go up what section
will you be in that's your uh to twelve
to twelve I'll be sure to try to when
you guys go to to twelve you know what I
will look for it
oh my god I mean I'm going to go
everywhere and they're all over MetLife
Stadium if you watched on but uh and
Smackdown live in Baltimore I went all
over Royal Farms in a matter of four
minutes that's true minutes I got
outside
it was raining you guys think I don't
care you can rain snow you bring bring
whatever New York has your goddamn I've
stayed you got a mailman I am sir a
sleet or snow for this match that that I
just I can't wait for people to witness
it do you sit there and go like wow you
know pinfalls count anywhere we can make
a real spectacle out of this match we're
gonna this is my opportunity to create a
WrestleMania moment do you think I nose
turns and everyone does yeah everyone
wants to have that WrestleMania moment
everyone wants to have match of the
night and this time there's what 15
matches yeah so I mean there's gonna be
a lot of matches and everyone's fighting
to have that top spot I mean honestly
it's for the first time ever the women
have the main event mm-hmm Charlotte
Flair Becky Lynch and Ronda Rousey for
the first time ever and all women's
match triple threat in the main event
and I think it's well deserved I think
those girls really held it down and
deserve the main event spot and I think
that everyone's gonna put on an absolute
fantastic performance their story is
incredible yeah I I'm excited to see it
I'm excited to see a lot of matches out
there you know this this this Sunday but
don't think for one second I'm not going
out there and putting giving it all I
have now now you said is it different
going up against a McMahon and the
answer is yes and no yes in yes it is a
McMahon that that is a you know it's
it's the name
McMahon but every time I go out there no
matter if it's you know a live event in
gypsy New York or MetLife Stadium in you
know 80,000 people strong I go out there
with the same attitude same mentality
I'm gonna give it everything I have I'm
gonna create a moment that will last a
lifetime I want a child to be with their
parents and be able to talk about that
moment until they're grownups and maybe
talk about it to their children and to
their children so you want a young child
to go like remember the time that I saw
the mrs. fist go through Shane McMahon's
face absolute 100% look I remember tell
children not to try it at home because
it's a very dangerous dangerous sport
yeah yeah
putting fists through faces is dangerous
it should do it kids should not do it
you're trained professional you know how
to put your fist enjoy it enjoy the
larger-than-life characters enjoy the
storylines being interactive you know
boo who you hate sure who you love but
don't try it at home right we are
trained professionals now before I let
you go cuz we have to release them is
that right that's unfortunate do you do
could you sit here for how long are you
here for three hours yeah we're here for
three hours a day three hours a day you
sit here for three hours with me it'd be
exhausting at a point but except right I
mean you know exhausted right now no
it's too much talking like what are you
gonna talk about now well we were
talking about Joe Biden before you came
in and all the all the you know Paulo
your political guy we got talking about
everything you do not seem like a
political guy first of all means you
seem like talking about poopoo humor
that's what I look at you and I go this
guy literally just talked about you know
I took a dump today and I took a picture
of it and I said you didn't think I was
a powerlifter either so how much you
know yeah you look like a power lift
thank you thank you so how much you know
here's what I want to know though you
know when the women were not main
eventing every time the women would talk
they're like you know what we're gonna
go out in the spot that we're in and
we're gonna try to outshine everybody
improve to the people why we should be
main eventing is there a spirit not that
anybody doesn't want the women to main
event but is there a spirit amongst some
of the guys that goes okay now is our
opportunity to remind people why we're
gonna have the best man everyone fights
for the main event yeah everyone trust
me and trust me there we're competitive
by Nature whether you're a man or a
woman people are competitive especially
in this sport
bunch of sharks and if you show a little
weakness you're gonna be eaten alive and
that's why I've been here for 13 years
because I'm the biggest shark of them
all but yes I mean obviously I want to
be in the main event I've had the main
event yeah and I don't want it to be a
one-hit wonder I wanted to go again and
again and again this year I do believe
that the women deserve it the women have
put on you know clinics whether it was
evolution and Nassau Coliseum I listened
to that audience I was in the crowd
watching these these these women you
know for the first time ever have an
all-women's pay-per-view and it was it
was incredible and that is a tough arena
yeah that arena New York has the
toughest audience if they love you they
will showcase how much they love you but
if they don't like you
there is crickets and let me tell you
some NASA Coliseum evolution all women's
pay-per-view that place the roof was
blown off it was absolutely incredible
it was awesome there was real chairs it
wasn't sympathy chairs it wasn't like is
a story behind the every single match it
felt like it was a main event well you
know it all cumulates
to sunday for all the hard work and
dedication and not just these women I'm
talking generations of women my wife
Maurice you know Trish Stratus Lita you
talk about all the greats for from from
previous generations coming in and now
we have the first women's uh you know
tag-team champions you know Natalie and
and Sasha you know putting their titles
up so don't get eaten alive eat a
Snickers no you're just not you and you
don't have a Snickers that's right good
thing I had one I've had one this
morning you know and that's why I'm so
on you're on you're on fire get a
Snickers bar it says awesome on the
front Dollar General yeah go to dollar
just get it you can go to uh get a
creamy peanut butter you can get creamy
almond butter but get a Snickers awesome
bar back down the counter on or you
should be eating almond butter do you
eat peanut butter not almond butter
almond butter is better for you okay
I'll take the bats I'll take that into
consideration so so if you didn't learn
anything here today oh one thing almond
butter is better than peanut butter
right of course the miz and miz's is
back yeah how did you like the show I
thought I was great did you watch it I
watched the first suit
with half-hour yeah the whole thing
what was your favorite part your dad was
acting like oh what are we gonna do
you're a big liar that's not true show
my wife fell asleep we didn't watch the
show I watched it you didn't watch the
show we're the same apart
I like when your wife is like I'm is
what are we gonna do with you she was
like I measure up to craziness again and
you're like watch my show and you go
like this was our premiere Murray's like
is not what happened our show is not
like any other show on television no no
no you don't get those we you're smart
we are funny I know I'm like
entertaining and why not a jerk for not
watching watch it all the time every
Tuesday and just after season 3 it's
amazing time to be smooth season 2 you
dummy didn't it just get season 3 oh
this is a continuation of season 1 we
just got picked up for 20 episodes
before the continuation even started
we got picked up for 20 more episodes
that's how much USA is behind it so you
don't care this is still season 1 you
always find a way to really annoy me and
really upset me you know we had such a
great conversation I walked in here
today I was so happy I was like you know
what good to see you Sam I'm so
obviously but one thing is for sure
right I always find a way to really
upset me did you watch miz and miz's
this last two so you can tell the
audience so you can check it out on
demand just you can't on USA Network
comp or things you watch the damn show
yeah it was great I watched Smackdown I
watched miz and miz's they hate you they
hate you more than life itself
no what was your favorite part I'm a
real moment that happened on the show
you were like man this wrestling stuff I
nuts
I'm gonna throw this computer through a
window right in your little studio good
app I hate you so much right now the
ratings came in and they were strong
right right in part one of those boys
was me you know not like you not like
you're playing my deadlift no you oh my
god I hate him I hate him so much can I
leave can I can leave I don't know by
the way I wasn't asking you may be
asking my
to assist oh if I could leave okay okay
my glam squad if you world I'm out of
here
where anyway watch miz and miz's yeah
every Tuesday after Smackdown live on
USA Network it's a great show
I'm as you need a Snickers I'm not here
right now I know I am being this is the
more me than I've ever been in my entire
life I cannot believe you didn't watch
miz and miz's I saw most do not look
because you didn't even tell me apart
you gonna told me they'll be kidding
yeah I'm gonna watch the middle the end
you could have told me apart you can't
even tell me a part from the show that
you like oh you were like ah Maurice
your mom what's she doing knew I was
coming in today yeah no oh it's coming
in I started to talk about Snickers
mainly interviewer and a professional
yeah you think you would you would get a
little knowledge on what I do I was all
on board with the ice cream bar stuff I
knew I was right there with you go there
when it's candy but then when it's when
it's something like miz and miz's you
don't think about it you got so much
stuff like you want me to watch six
marine movies and Smackdown and miz and
miz's it's your job aren't you gonna be
there at MetLife working yeah I will but
what I can't talk about miz and miz's on
the kickoff yes you are
you better jeez you're getting cranky in
your AC oh my god I hate you I hate I
hate him I'm done we're gonna take a
brand on we'll be back no I'll take a
break no I'm letting you go okay letting
me go I'm letting you go take play it
now we're done one more Jim and Sam
catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the Sirius XM f